i want to just ask some advice and
selfishly take a moment um
i never
when we were younger and single and free
and like just you know getting started
revving our engines and i never knew
that we would be sitting here i know
right and i would be asking like talk
show advice
that's crazy right not only are we
parents we both have talk shows i mean
what did you what have you learned
since day one of the show until now
what's like the overarching aha moment
that may have taken years
to learn but now you know
i think people don't want to watch
you as a host
stress in real time about how the show's
going because in the early days of the
show every monologue joke that didn't
work i feel like the audience could see
on my face
like oh
and i just don't think especially when
you're watching a show like mine at 12
30 at night they don't want to see some
host white knuckling it through a
monologue um and so it was just like
giving myself the permission to be
comfortable with it and know that not
everything
is going to be the best joke people have
ever heard but that there'll be humor in
watching maybe the worst joke they've
ever heard uh go badly in a room full of
people and so that is a thing that you
know i think carson did better than
anyone johnny carson um and then second
place carter he's on his show many times
yeah i cannot like that's the craziest
thing 1982 carson yeah and then i did a
show many times
that's amazing how many times do you
think you did johnny carson probably
five six seven and i also did it with uh
joan rivers and jay lena when they would
sub in for him okay so what are your
favorite segments of your show now well
you know we have this segment called the
closer look is like 15 minutes 12 to 15
minutes every day and it's just so nice
to know that's going to be the sort of
the meat of our show and the the biggest
part of our writing any day and it just
helps us you know process the news of
the day and then we do sillier things we
did a thing last night that's sort of
new called surprise inspection where we
read all the worst monologue jokes that
our writers turned in over the course of
a month oh my god don't they don't know
they're doing it and we show their
pictures and um
they're really they're mostly like just
terrible puns or massively offensive and
that's a very fun thing to do
um okay there's another segment that
people love called day drinking yeah day
drinking i used to be a huge day drinker
i mean i liked partying early and ending
early yeah um so rihanna
uh did day drinking with you 18 million
views this has what was that like i
think nine million are for me and nine
million or fewer
that was uh
look it was
it was an exceptional it was an
exceptional afternoon she's a really
wonderful down-to-earth person and she
was really it was great to afternoon
booze with her you gotta say my god what
a bucket list also the other thing is i
uh i this i think speaks to the fact
that i'm uh older than rihanna um
at the end of that i went home and fell
asleep in my hallway outside
outside my apartment door and i'm pretty
sure she went out
yeah and like started a new business oh
yeah right she went out to like have
like meetings with angel investors yeah
[Music]
you